welcome back to the
show it's Tuesday no 14 have a great
guest for you her return to the show
finally I'm so excited to have her I'm
glad we could fit her in this schedule I
know she's going to be very busy out
speaking in all those R areas to tell
them why they actually are blue this is
important stuff this is important work
that she does her name is Jess pip and
you we've had her on the show she's one
of your favorite the audience's favorite
guest and this morning I was reading a
story about Wick and Wick payments and
it seemed to be that there's a new study
that showed that Missouri and
Arkansas and other states but Missouri
and
Arkansas have a low participation lead
I'm talking below 40% which was kind of
weird to me I was like this is federal
funding this isn't State funding and I
text my friend Jess Piper and I said
this does not seem like a coincidence
and she said it is not it is planned so
I said come on the show and let's let's
talk about this we gotta talk about
this and you know smoke this out give
this awareness so welcome back Jess
Piper I'm so glad to have you my friend
here on the Tony Michaels podcast hey
Tony it's good to see you again so tell
us you're traveling around the state
doing these speeches and I know you're
we we kind of fit in the schedule for
today so tell us about these speeches
and then we'll get to the wick stuff um
and I'm sure we'll talk about education
too because it's j Viper so yeah I'm
going to be in St Louis tomorrow I'm
speaking to a group of people who are
trying to get uh Empower other women to
run and then really fun on col um on
Thursday Friday I'm in Columbia on
Thursday Springfield on Friday and it's
a Clean Water conference so I'm speaking
with um experts on a panel about what's
happening with Missouri's water we have
a scientist coming down from Iowa
because I know people think about the
water in Iowa probably that it's or
something but it's actually full of hog
and um and so those people have now
ruined Iowa and now they're looking
South to Missouri and um so I'm hitting
the road with these people to talk about
how we can save our water in Missouri
you know it's kind of funny that we sit
here and have to um beat back these
fascists with Pro Federal programs where
our state isn't participating like Wick
um where it's it's helped it's it's it
is designed to help fight childhood
hunger and child hunger um where
Missouri is doing so much thing so many
things in education and um school
lunches and it's insane that we have to
sit here and and talk about these
subjects that should be pretty easy
feeding kids should not be that
controversial that way we we could pay
attention to things like hog in the
water um but you know because Farmers
rely on those waterways I don't know if
people know that and your food on your
table relies on those waterways being
clean so it it's all you know a big loop
and we're all in this together um but
why why is this Wick thing because I I
read the story this morning I'm like and
I sent it to you and I thought um she's
got to know about this I know she's got
her thumb on this one so tell me why if
I was to say that this is oh it's
totally a coincidence that Missouri and
Arkansas are below 40% participate tell
me why I'm wrong I know I'm not I know
I'm not but tell me why I'm wrong you're
not wrong and this is how I know I am
originally from Arkansas so I made the
lateral move uh to Missouri and um it's
because that we live under super
majorities who often send back federal
funds for absolutely no reason I don't
know if you remember but during coid um
the federal government sent us millions
of dollars to give to Hungry kids who
weren't in school it took Missouri an
entire year to disperse those funds um
the kids were already back in school by
the time they got those funds and then
Tony last year or last session Mike
Parson returned $47 million of federal
money uh for Hungry kids uh for their
lunches because we couldn't figure out
how to do disperse the fund so we just
sent it back well again Wick and you can
describe Wick probably better than I can
uh I I I know that you probably are very
familiar with the program and the ins
and outs of it and why it is so
important to to not just Missouri
families but American families it's the
reason why it's a federally funded
program um but I get so frustrated
because we we want States um cheer and
and they do such a great job of doing
school lunch for everyone um which
should be part of education I've always
felt like you know our communities have
infrastructure for hunger and the the
main infrastructure for Hunger is the
school cafeteria like that's like that's
the we didn't really realize it when we
decided to embark on public education so
many so many you know over a hundred
years ago but we we didn't understand
that we were going to build an
infrastructure that could feed
communities but that's literally what
that building does is it not only
educates students but it feeds those
children as well and I can't even
believe that we can't wrap our Minds
around that idea that we have the
infrastructure we have the ability to
make sure that kids kids we're talking
about and they save the children people
you know of all people are like no no
thank you we don't want the wick we
don't because tell me what what Wick is
and tell me why it's intentional that
Missouri it feels like to me in this in
this article that I had from the
Missouri independent that I sent you it
feels like to me that the Republicans of
Missouri aren't doing their due
diligence to let citizens know that hey
These funds are available for you not to
have to spend so much on groceries
because if you don't spend as much on
groceries maybe you won't blame your
plight on who I want you to blame it on
right because it feels like that's what
Republicans are truly doing yeah wh uh
Wick is women infant and children and so
it's a program for pregnant women and
women who have children I believe up to
um age five I actually participated in
the program um I had my first son at 20
years old I was married um and my
husband worked full-time and I worked
fulltime at Walmart but we still
couldn't make ends me and so it gave me
eggs and peanut butter and cereal and
milk things that I needed to to fill up
my son and things that were and beans
too things that were nutritionally good
for him what's happening in Missouri is
that uh most people who and this is
confusing to people most people who
participate in Wick also work we aren't
talking about people who aren't working
these are working folks um just like I
was and the problem with Missouri is you
have to go to your local um you know
Health Department to get your card
updated well you have to go during work
hours and so that makes it almost
impossible for working folks to fill
their card um at the same time every
other state nearly has figured this out
you do it online and it comes
automatically it's automatically filled
but in Missouri we make working moms
take off and how are they going to take
off because they've lost some money and
then drive to their local you know um
DHS to fill that C up so we've made it
difficult for working folks to get
things that that they need and that the
federal government is providing so what
you're saying is because I read that in
the article that really there was a big
push during the pandemic because there
was extra money given to Wick because
during the pandemic they were trying to
overload uh families to make sure that
they had enough to eat I I I mean it's
crazy to think that you know we were
trying to make sure people weren't
hungry in this country uh as rich as we
are and as rich as we claim to be um but
the thing was is that Missouri was very
reluctant and by Missouri I mean
Republicans because that's who controls
the state they were very reluctant into
bringing that program on online and the
reason why is just what you're saying